girlfriend achillion first first part in
Hollywood courting there and this is
emergency contraceptive guys yeah we
keep it professional
sorry we're doing a show right now we
are now this is episode of your mom's
house has begun get out get out of here
it's going this is the coolest music
ever yeah you wait for it what if this
was the song this is the song do you
like it
yes we hear it right no no no there's no
song playing we tricked you we just
voted you out so hard your baby exploded
this episode of your mom's house is
brought to you by amazon.com if you go
to your mom's house podcast.com you can
click on the amazon banner and you can
shop for all the stuff you were normally
going to buy the nice thing about this
sales pitch is it's not asking you to
buy something you wouldn't already
that's right you already want to go buy
some fake blood or a GG Allin bobblehead
or some neck pillows and you thought I'm
gonna go to any other side beard trimmer
maybe oh yeah period I highly endorse
you should be going to Amazon anywhere
every time you go to a store and look at
anything over $30 you should just read
laser it and then find out how much is
on Amazon and just really no tax there
you go
what you need right then just do it
Amazon listen Ari he knows what he's
talking about go to the shopper but
definitely go to your machine II shopper
okay you're a shopper yeah but go
through your mom's house podcast calm
and click on the amazon banner and oh by
the way we should say and when I want to
am I'm gonna make it clear thank you to
everybody that has because a lot of you
have tweeted us that you you went there
and we appreciate it
it definitely helps it helps you know
with the cost of running this
multi-billion dollar operation these
cameras that you're seeing the bandwidth
the skittles that work you can go out on
me the Ustream that I haven't figured
out yet all of those things cost money
and you're supporting us and also of
course we want to thank our sponsors
Spotify if you look on your mom's house
podcast calm there's another banner
there and I keep getting emails every
day of Spotify uh-huh it's the shit
right yeah yeah I get emails every day
if you get the song you want you do it
everyone and
the like the audio quality is higher you
don't the wait for it down it just plays
alright yeah so with a we've a banner
right next to the Amazon one and if you
click on that banner you can go sign up
for about 90 seconds and have every song
basically ever every song that's every
court anything you want yeah and you
don't have to listen to a bunch of other
garbage you don't want to you don't
listen to any what's another one called
Pandora
you guys got Chris tingle did a bit of
better about how that works you find a
band you really like you type that in
and then they promise to never play that
yeah no yeah just say everything similar
yeah or they play the one song by that
man you don't want to hear yeah a nice
shady song I like about Spotify is like
you can literally just be like whatever
you're thinking about it like Fugees and
then or your catalogue comes out yeah
that's actually where your song I'm
always whenever I do that I have to go
to the illegal download side right no we
didn't even know is it's free just go
click on the banner and it's free you
don't have to buy something just click
on it sign up it's yours easy and we put
the the amazon banner for the Canadians
the Canucks couldn't shop as a regular
one so if you go on our your mom's house
podcast calm click on the the scroll
down on the right hand side we put the
banner there and of course your emails
are always appreciated your mom's
podcast at gmail.com and you can tell us
your thoughts and your stories and how
much and your dental updates yeah which
hey maybe you'll get one this episode um
you guys ever get an email it starts
with I don't know if you guys ever like
read all of this oh yeah every we
definitely do yeah you know and I said
god I just got miss whisset up here oh I
just got I'm sure you get um I said
listen young on Pandora you're one of
the funniest communes overheard I know
you probably get like a billion of these
a day but I just want to say I'm a big
fan
and I responded with I definitely don't
get these a day like I'm just so
overwhelmed yeah I'm I have Chris Rock's
fanbase but bro on time thank you very
much uh goodbye I know bags and fan mail
pouring in or sell out arenas but I have
that was the old cliche thing was as
soon as you get popular they were just
dump bags overflow the montage of your
fame and success and movies no now it's
just Twitter this you can find you
instantly know fuck you bitch is
everybody is there a problem with
anything this is the point where you
have to go talk about what the problem
is there a problem does anyone say
there's a problem I don't see any
problems oh yeah
I'm just making sure how many of these
are you done like this we've done live
verse five or six I like that right life
I mean like yeah about six six episodes
streaming to all our live listeners can
you tell me if the audio is cool um
everything we see knows no sound alright
no sound at all that's last-minute
desire favor I don't me see hold on
I know if you're if you're listening to
the audio and you're like oh cool that's
weird because I'm seeing the sound
levels move on this thing so you think
someone's fucking with you
yes you think that's what happening well
I'm seeing the sound meter jump on
Ustream so that's usually the audio is
good it says from yes yeah okay okay
I just conquered a liar oh I don't know
there's not so much I can see mm and all
up in my ass I don't fucking know
everything is cool and perfect audio is
okay everybody's happy with your gun all
right great oh where you gonna be next
Christina uh this week I will be in West
Nyack New York that's just 45 minutes
outside of New York City at levity lie
that's what won't be yeah I'm just so
excited I hear it's awesome and I can't
wait to do it yeah how big is it it's
like the one in Phoenix I don't know
honestly I don't know but it's a massive
that place probably totally into selling
out I mean probably already sold out
what about you Tommy buns I'm gonna be
at the Dayton funny bone
July 5th through 8th and then let's see
I'm I'm back in town and then the next
place that I go after the date and
funnybone is the Richmond funnybone July
19 through 20 seconds so Dayton Ohio get
at me day I'm a Dayton motherfuck yeah
and then Richmond I'm going to to pretty
much chocolate cities really I was
dating chocolate thing Dayton is for
Katt Williams is from yes oh she's as
real as a kiss that's fine yeah and then
Richmond every only one so judgment
Richmond's Little Mix I remember last
time but I'm saying that's one of
Richmond's nicknames is chocolate city
I'm a Chinese cities other there's a few
you know Richmond has claimed it for a
long time yeah DC has called itself yeah
say before I didn't know there are
multiple chat Lana oh yes I'm just
calling it yeah sorry
Detroit rock with sauce man Atlanta is
really blue really like it's really
black I'm from the greater DC area yeah
good girl and like Jesus
now wait so where are you gonna be
working people see you real quick they
can see Montreal I'm doing my
storyteller show yeah it shows yeah
what's also doing all drugstores all
drugs and alcohol stories that's right I
got to do that last year yeah and the
reviewer didn't like me who said
bullshit reviewers they're just there to
ruin honestly like I watched I watched
like all of them I definitely like told
I thought like a real story it was a
good story
it had like that was in our room there
were laughs it was that was the one that
was Hannibal me Russell and somebody
else know that your story was that about
Peru no it was about North Africa oh
yeah but it was it was a fun and I was
like this guy didn't have enough jokes I
was like it was a story God liked about
it I was so disappointed I did watch the
next night - when you had Bill burr
DeRosa and oakerson and suggest a story
was so good so good no but that shit
felt like it was like that was like a
that could have you could have taken
what he said yeah and shot it the next
day as a like a sketch yeah it was oh
yeah these I'd be here perfect yeah it
was a perfect story yeah I remember that
going like that was the best one
like hand of the whole thought of the
whole thing so Montreal you can see re
there and it's called um the show is
called I was so fucked up I was so
fucked up you have a lineup already now
we're just getting to reveal Brendon
Walsh is doing the first night work
we're probably both career mushrooms
okay so maybe you'll tell Velcro Wow
probably the next Tony wasn't able to
tell maybe maybe that's called a story
and you can always find re at re the
great are the great and I'll be in the
first weekend of August I'll be in that
place in New Jersey stress factory
awesome how cool guys been there I had
no I know I was I did a Gotham a few
weeks ago and I ran into Tommy John
again on the plane he was on his way
there really had said he had a good time
afterwards yeah I got Kermit's gonna
open for me we got to start the show
here we go party the greatest feeling
you can get in a jam oh the most
satisfying feeling you can get in the
gym
is the pump let's say you drain your
biceps
blood is rushing into your muscles and
that's what we call the pump you muscles
get a really tight feeling like your
skin is going to explode any minute you
know it's really tight it's like
somebody blowing air into into your
muscle it just blows up and it feels
different it feels fantastic it's a
satisfying to me as coming is you know
as having sex with a woman and coming
so can you believe how much I am in
heaven I'm like getting the feeling of
coming in the gym I'm getting the
feeling of coming at home I'm getting
the feeling of coming backstage when I
pump up when I pose out in front of
5,000 people I get the same feeling so
I'm coming day and night
I mean it's terrific right well
Christina
all right here we go your bad okay that
sounded like my dad was that my dad that
was your death
how did Schwarzenegger win Governor of
California how do they not just play
that while he was running the other side
did did cuz this is from a documentary
yes probably need yes man in the
documentary smokes weed in the
documentary best ever you have your
nursing pumping iron oh you have heard
about a lot how can I possibly enjoy
that it's such a good it's a no really
you have to think about the fact that
like maybe like on its own you might be
like I don't really care about this but
he's such an iconic figure that it's
like I thought just him showing people
how to work out no no it's all this
personality basic and it there's a
battle him and the holic Lou frig no
we're going head-to-head going at it and
wasn't like the brash young punk who
showed the old guy no respect
uh well Lou was like this you know more
of the what do you call it like the
superstar no he wanted he Arnold is a
superstar when they're shooting it and
Lou is like this kind of like this guy
like he's this way then he's very sweet
much more shy you know he has a heavy
speech impediment he's hearing impaired
and and his dad is like his you know
deaf talks right and his dad's like this
you know his coach is trainer oh really
the Arnold's like like tournament like
Arnold goes like he plays like fake
intimidate he's like look how big and
strong you are really really strong you
really have it but he gets in there like
he fucks with every shit talks yeah you
should talk to Lou Ferrigno who's like
the sweetest lamb on the plant he's
really mean he fucking he he is in
charge dude I saw I met with Lou
Ferrigno ones he's a big fuck yeah I was
taking acting class with his wife really
hearing I was dating outside smoking in
there like the entranceway and I noticed
it was like staring at me in the car
like I turned cuz I felt it and then he
said shouldn't smoke I know
Wow cool and I turned back you got it
but then I turned back again like a
minute later and he goes I said you
shouldn't smoke
and I put it up and then he and then he
ripped his shorts
listen what but I thought Lou Ferrigno's
dad wasn't a real I thought it was a
real abusive piece of shit to Lou
growing up and that's why we became a
bodybuilder that might be true I
couldn't confirm or deny that he's
definitely he's one of those like you
stories you saw a million times of like
the you know the dad that wanted the kid
to be the athlete so he was he was he
was the you know real aggressive coaches
fob you know or or kids coach you know I
mean who's the dad who's like you're
gonna fucking be the best shirt but he
had he had a fucking specimen as a son
the guy's six seven like 260 that's
crying all muscle it's pretty creepy
made even bigger than me like 275 he had
like 2% body fat
really he's him he was he's a fucking I
mean he's the Hulk you know yeah you
have Tim growing up he's rich um the
whole body was like so good hold him do
you know um Schwarzenegger in that
documentary he's only about I think 28
years old and he knows at the age of 20
s like I'm going to be a superstar I'm
going to be movies I'm going to be like
this guy had delusional aspirations no
but um he was 28 and he just he just
came to America in his 20 and maybe was
25 when he landed here I don't want to
go here I don't think he did dad what
did he do something like he definitely
posed and I don't know I think anything
but that guy he was accomplish it right
away I mean you think about - he won
that um mr. universe or mr. Olympia
whichever one is seven times and that's
bananas
so you know that's like a as a their
highest competition yeah they just like
now has just me man in this every single
year Lance Armstrong style Lance
Armstrong style but Schwarzenegger did
it with no help of it actually he did he
did he admits to it was there yeah but
yeah also that was the norm yeah it
wasn't there was it wasn't like a
behind-the seeing the scenes thing that
like you're being tested and I think it
is now hmm back then and they also
didn't have the HGH wasn't the level and
the test you know the the testosterone
that they would take the good stuff it's
not like the stuff that it's out there
today they all did it they all would
work out and
shoot up you know take a shot yeah but
fucking Lance is uh
I gotta believe I have work here you
talked about this before too and that is
that if people keep talking about it
well it's like what is there to gain by
going after somebody who you feel like
like he's also retired but like here's
the thing like why I tarnish lying why
try to like do you really feel like
there's a witch-hunt
just because in other words like Michael
Jordan people don't fucking say yeah
there would be and and I I believe
obviously that he did not and I feel
like the point of that would be what
like why would you want to tarnish this
amazing accomplishment of his seven
right isn't it seven like our seven Tour
de France titles which is it's
unbelievable just to fucking take that
away from I believe that something has
happened with him that you know I mean I
feel like there's something there
mm-hmm you mean there's you you you hear
of all these other could it be some guy
who really wanted a nail on but couldn't
this many good there's two there's not
one guy they're not discrediting like
one disgruntled former employee there
are entire groups and now like the
anti-doping agency is coming out being
like their test from this year is
tainted like how they coming up with us
now three years later he hasn't raced in
a unit yet he's it's never really died
down there but can i really give you
that much of an advantage today a
seven-year i mean though the guy had
accountable no it's not but that much of
an advance in that in that like elite
level that level of competition Tour de
France is like basically making like 30
or 50 home runs yeah I mean what what it
has to do with is likely you're not
going to hit a baseball because you take
steroids right you're not going to be
able to all sudden cycle but the big
thing about like cycling it in the in
what they do is your ability to recover
mm-hmm and because like a Tour de France
is like a multi-day it's like a two-week
you're just biking like fucking hundred
miles a day
sounds and so it's the recovery it's
like what your blood and body is capable
of that that rest period how you can
recover to do that again the next day
and again the next day and again the
next day things baseball was that yeah
it's not you're not hitting the ball
because you take steroids but when
you're thirty five thirty eight forty
and shit
normal ligaments joints at muscles are
fuckin going out on you Wow but you're
recovering you 162 game season and
you're just like bouncing back that's
the event
oh I'm 36 and I ride an airplane for a
day and I'm like a cripple I can't get
up a new happy dude yeah like yeah
you're just in your 30s or your decline
is so rapid at least - cuz I don't do
shit but do you exercise re fuck no okay
no no no I brought it usually huh uh-huh
be stopped yeah stopped just got too
hard and was getting in real-time busy
got staph infections and just bring
worms once you do steroid stuff just
there it's no thanks just do steroids
and then when you're I probably would
wholly I was sure I'd that sounds like a
new segment about to break yeah I don't
know let's invent one honey man I didn't
have something for that what was it it
was steroids steroids Saturdays yeah
something something really should see
the level I saw a documentary on
steroids and there's no evidence that
long-term steroid use actually has any
negative effects there's really I don't
think that's Chancellor and that well
here's the thing I take hormones I tell
you birth control right yeah shakin it
since I was fucking 15 years old and
women have been doing it now for a long
time and isn't a hormone way too steroid
baby yeah same thing I do I mean I don't
know we'll see if I grow like a third
tit okay what's up my baby but I don't
know I had to go buy science whatever
they're proven is the real thing
science is unreliable really yeah they
change their mind every fucking week on
the data there right no no you just go
buy whatever people say in your town
then well because science comes in and
out of fashion like I was listening to
this guy talk about how like now the use
of maggots is coming back to treat like
sores that aren't like incurable
yeah but just for a while was out of
fashion we used maggots in like the
medieval or Renaissance period or
whatever and then it went out of fashion
and now we use it again cuz it works
really it's just fashion I thought
there's like concrete evidence that
steroid use leads to can lead to cancer
and I think it leads to your bean bag
shrinking like side effects and stuff
right look on this documentary that I
saw on HBO really a few years back
they're like yeah there's no conclusive
evidence I thought was a definite
definite cameo they always seem to say
that that's lousy oh so you don't know
yeah he died yeah yeah but you know
documentary was maybe he fucking knows
blow to my doctor who knows man so hey
tell tari tell everybody what happened
was your last show was your last yeah
okay so I was I was in Dallas at hyena's
this week mmm shows are great fun crowds
um I did walk some black people but
other than so Saturday late show no
Saturday first show good set I'm bathing
in the adoration of the applause of
people well and I think to myself was
room still packed I'm not going to get
off the stage the way I normally know
how to and go all the way around to go
outside to meet people afterwards
because I meet people after the show
and Lola I thought I'm just going to
jump down and I look and it's all
shadows and darkness and people and I
take a little leap and I fall right on
my ass look at my ankle catches on the
step that was there and it might twist
my ankle I fall down yes and in between
like tables of people so they're all
like oh my god it's all shoe it's just
so good what did she do yeah and
mortified the audience is where I was I
was in pain you know when you when
something like that happens and you're
like oh fuck this hurts like I don't
know what to do and then I remember
people were watching me and I had to get
up then I got out performer yeah I was
like oh shit they're expecting me to
stand and I get up and I give like a
Mary Lou Retton like I'm alright
everybody but it was sad there's pain it
was so embarrassing and it was so
painful and then I got home last night
and I got from the couch and Tommy what
did you say you were like dude
you got up and you were wearing just
like a little nightie and I'm very
you make it sexy well you were to target
cotton but just like a little thing yeah
and then when you stood up you didn't
have any panties I when I come home I
take everything really I let my thing
breathe so I looked over and I saw like
a dark mark like a dark smudge right
around her butt crack and I was like in
my mind I was like I was you were
farting I was like a shit on a couch so
yeah I was like oh like you babe you got
shit everywhere and then I was like hey
let me take a look at that and you're
like what and I looked you have this big
black yeah dark bruise yeah I'm good
right like on her butt cheek but going
from the cheek all the way to the crack
really yeah I'm falling on my ass in
Dallas and I was like oh you think I
didn't shit cause all I think is like
please don't shoot don't shit the couch
that would suck that we got ya
light-colored couches
- all right Kia couch is at the throat
if I can catch out I will say dad talk
to get shit often watch could you watch
the hearth and flip the couch yeah my
dad should his pants a few weeks ago
when I was with them yeah you know with
them I was with him yeah and uh and I
was like I just just throw those eyes
like they're fine I was like you shit
yeah you don't see it anyway he held
them up he was like there's no shit I'm
like just just wide up you can afford
other pastor calculus he kept him he
didn't throw him out shit my pants went
to the comedy store no like we're doing
like competitive farting you know we
like I like the phone yeah yeah I'm with
Dave Michelle back upstairs outside
Duncan's office and I lifted my legs and
then I was like that was wet I was
feeling those no I threw them right out
see I wanna rest out into them yeah and
it's instinct you like you know like
Aussies looking up what are we gonna do
with the whole shit you can't wash that
you can't really why would you want your
little shit in there when I was little I
used to shit myself all the time I feel
like right and your mom would just wash
it yeah present which is I guess what
you do with kids kind of what you do
yeah wait so did you light your farts
too or it was just never got to that
really I'm like I feel like you would be
really good at it
letting it farts yeah
does it really work it works yeah I
swear to God Charlie yeah Charlie's done
it
ya know seen Charlie and you dozens of
times it works he sits back throws the
legs up yeah it gets the light you he
puts the light just under just under his
asshole yeah did you hear that yeah oh
and you see Oh like that just a quick
flash yeah so it's like a microsecond
after this I've seen him do it doesn't
I'm not yeah that's pretty fantastic I
wanna see that yeah it's great
he's really good at it I always just
thought no way could be oh yeah you did
well my ex roommate Kevin Jensen used to
do it yeah and he was a chance
booth fuck this Kevin guy you know I
love what Kevin Henson it was Shauna's
my Shauna's friend Kevin we all lived
together in San Francisco and one night
in my dorm rooms in England they came to
visit me and we just sat on a circle and
lit our farts I swear to god it's really
funny tears - I was too afraid - but
what I did do is I farted into a film
kit container like you know those black
ones are rated you know five millimeter
one did you know that if you fart into
it and then seal it immediately and then
hand it to someone and they open it they
smell the fart oh that makes sense me
and Annie are you think you're talking
to rookies other guys any jar right like
any airtight container it'll hold the
smell for like a long time yeah you can
it's not just the you can answer the
person nicely you can mail that shit to
somebody why don't we try an experiment
is there someone organs coast we can
mail Jane let's do it let's see list
yeah you should do that yeah that is a
really good little in California air for
you we could actually decorate it and
then and then write a note like this is
all like the rave in Beverly Hills yeah
it's like it's a new scent yes a new
thing yeah and like all like the like
celebrities are doing uh ha ha ha that's
a listen scooby-doo this last line a lot
shot great is what happened to Scooby do
they do that
there were screams they couldn't screen
the screamer the bottle and seal it up
oh really
cork come off in the screen will come
out see the writers knew about the new
around the art trick
have you ever burped in your mouth and
you held it let it ferment in there for
all the time leave it for people just
right over the shoulder you know what I
do is like a lot of times it'll just
come up like I'll just be dead and then
also and I come into my mouth and then
I'll be like oh and like it's like right
before like I meet somebody new like and
agent is here to talk to you now and
I'll be like hey and I'm like oh just
fuckin oh yeah you've done that official
meeting just get my belly I've done that
to important people like oh yeah hey I'm
Tom they're like you're disgusting yeah
you farted - in conference before fuck
is wrong with you
raisin a body not a hole that a little
bit if I was gonna be able to letting go
yeah all the time to me we have metal we
walk down the street the other day
morning at each other another guy a guy
parked his car and he got out we're
walking it that's what he walks in the
same direction but he cuts in front of
us cuz he he just parked
cuz he walking like he just parked his
car
I go burp and he turned he was like but
like offended like he turned like how
dare you
ouch like that we're outside man like
I'm not in your house right he's nice to
someone yeah yeah so one well in all
fairness he kind of walked in on our
part of the sidewalk I mean he wasn't
there for the beginning I wouldn't do
the turn around he turned he turned
gradually turn around he gave me a
disapprovingly yeah he scolded you with
his eyes really oh yeah stuff I like it
when people do that to you I feel like a
kid all the time yeah yeah yeah the fun
thing is though as an adult though if
you get that kind of look as an adult
now you can be like what's the problem
well fuck yourself like that's the
things you wanted to do as a kid we're
the same age yeah around I decided to
belch today what are you gonna do about
it I curse sometimes in public and uh
and uh people like turn oh yeah then I
want to get embarrassed but I'm like
wait this is the language I use yeah the
language thing kills me you know what
really kills me
well I almost get to it to a degree you
just put an altar shit out yeah it's
hurt my back do you have something I
want to take out no the language thing I
used to I was like I'm not doing a bit
research I was I was I used to have a
bit about this but it's so real to me
that it bothers me so much is when like
grown men react like act like language
bothers them but like a grown man with
white hair
yeah who's fucking 50 years old not only
cut it down you almost definitely use it
come on and they do and they're like
give you a disapproving or they like I
worked with a guy I worked for a guy one
time it was like hey you know what's
like really well you're a 50-year old
man and you're offended that I said this
asshole like that's yeah you're grown up
that what level of lying do you live
your yeah yeah yes like it was a
comedian that passed away and he made a
video about people that don't curse he's
sitting on a stoop oh you're talking
about a brother no Mike did this no no
no yeah yeah and he was like I don't I
don't trust people that don't curse
I don't either and I agree like you're a
grown-up you inhabit an adult world full
of adult situations and you can't handle
the you're saying that's not the right
word sometimes yeah I mean I understand
that like you know there's of course as
beats there's such thing as being crude
there such thing as using language
inappropriate right situations mate you
know and I understand it's someone's
little funeral I understand fly kit
really if you're like look I don't want
my kids hearing that all right man but
if we're all adults it around I'm like
you wouldn't believe this shit and
someone's gonna have like a hey excuse
me like are you serious right now like
you don't like yeah you're amazing I'd
say to them that's that's that's a lie
in and of itself in a way that you're
acting like you're censoring real life
mmm-hmm
so inauthentic to me even the thing with
kids I don't have kids so I can't really
speak about it but I know that my
parents never censored language around
me and I don't know what's the big deal
yeah the kid hears fuck growing up or
shadow things I think it's I think
you're doing that kid a favor more you
are harm by not not that you want to
like yell that at the kid all day but
you're going to tell me
me like that kid's gonna hear it yeah so
what you mean like this is bullshit that
kid's gonna be like oh my god I can't
believe well yeah you said it because
that's what people say and now he's
gonna know that people say that exactly
okay and I did get in trouble like when
I was in first grade I yelled fuck
during bingo okay I lost a bingo and I
was like fuck but you know what happened
what I got spanked
right cuz at my school they were
spanking at the time yeah some old lady
yeah some quick to a Lutheran School and
this old woman spanked my ass and you
know what I learned
don't say fuck at school right fuck at
home you can say fuck wherever you learn
the parameters yeah and I also I reject
the idea that if you curse you know it
means you have a limited vocabulary
sometimes the curse words the best word
yeah sometimes fuck motherfucker goddamn
it shit those are the best words yeah to
express yeah what if you get kids in the
shin yeah
ah just dagnabbit darn it
yeah sizzle sticks cheese and rice this
really this hurts a lot right but how
often you guys fuck up on the radio when
you go to pretty good at it
really I do they're like oh we got to
dump that and like oh that I just cursed
I believe it yeah I usually don't even
know yeah like oh like what would I
bring up that shouldn't but up I don't I
know I'm pretty good at it
I've only been dumped out a couple times
I don't even realize yeah actually it's
I think if you really but you know that
one when the times that I've they've had
to dump me is when we've had like really
good conversation so I really like I
become my god yeah that is a bunch of
bullshit mm-hm
yeah it's your job as a parent to say
well we don't want you using that word
our son but other people do we don't
want you murdering either but yeah we'll
do but the thing about the kid thing is
I feel like that kid's gonna say that
the kids gonna say eventually they're
he's gonna hear it I'm gonna get in here
gonna cross my eyes just not gonna hear
it from you okay - doesn't one of us
wait so you guys I that was so
embarrassing falling off stage have you
guys ever done that before just me
what's the worst thing that's happening
thing that's happened to you oh man
my dick out so many times on stage
that's intentional though right now what
embarrassing at all yeah I know that
before I even met him before I knew who
he was
may I knew who he was I'd never met him
I saw him I saw you were naked
out not only naked or take your dick out
you had no pants no underwear on and we
were at this Westside like theater the
underground this comedy underground Mike
black was on - and you walked from like
the backroom he walked and you were you
walked in a circle around him with no
pants and we're on and then you just
walked off relation set right it was
really hilarious like I'd done a set I
don't know you then I got off that I'm
sitting there and I had Charlie and my
first room is so this was like 2003 yeah
and all sudden like Mike's on stage
doing his set oh no he's like talk about
John Candy or some shit and I'm looking
at him and then I see a guy walking
right
yeah he's wearing a t-shirt Donald Duck
in in a gray t-shirt and shoes no no
pants no underwear he's just nothing but
on that was the first places are doing
it really he walked up and and then mics
are 11:00 we are like oh my Mike the guy
was with Jack my first room is is
drinking a beer a ghost I'm shooting out
and how I just walked in a circle around
Mike with his dick out and then walks
off stage did Mike know you're gonna do
that probably not I don't remember that
like so no I've been arrested for that
no the first time I ever did a little
eclairs got really upset one time there
are the improv band me for six months
and yeah yeah I know and there was like
I was like clearly come on you don't
debate just I'm gonna do it no like do
you think this behaviour accepted
anywhere like yes who told you that it
was the lesson for like who did who gave
you the came from like Eric said he had
to tell me Eric here who said he had to
tell me what his bosses told him oh
really yeah he said they also wanted a
year we had to talk him down
Wow I think I'll get it they said yeah
if you ever want to do that again just
ask someone you know who works there
looking for art I was like would you
ever say yes know what like what was the
scenario in which you did it was that
guy who use Ben sticks or
um I met some guy who had a where's on
show they're at the improv I was like
rock and roll meets comedy yeah thing
those are so fucking down yeah who wants
it I forget the guys name now but um
yeah he had one it was just late and I
was drunk and at the bar and I like
gonna close up cuz somebody's on right
now and then I'm doing what like fuck
yeah let's do it
and then just no one was listening was
just crazy people screaming the whole
time and so I got some one of the porn
stars are in there to come up on stage
and I remind out talking her than I just
pull my dick out I had it people that
she know you were gonna do that you tell
her you and do that no no did she react
was she like oh my god I don't really
move really hey I really just do it with
the crowd and the crowd must have gone
nuts yeah a little bit yeah did you do
that I've done it better though HBO
mm-hmm you took your dick out yeah did
they let it in or cut it out barely let
it in I like like frame like I did and I
immediately shot my back Wow on HBO even
yeah they were gonna do again they were
really mad they were gonna cut it out
completely and say you have to come back
the next day because we're taking two
days different people were taping at
each day I said take this clothes off
don't get them stained yet the wear this
tomorrow because we can't even cut
around you because you fucking didn't
pull your pants up before you say
goodnight so which is I'm supposed to
know did uh did that crowd go bananas
today went nuts 1300 people 1300 yeah I
guess crowd I had done to that point
has anyone ever sent you a picture of
you they didn't even know like did you
expect like with it's like you forgot an
email there was some stills right then
if somebody freeze-frame to my dick out
oh yeah yeah yeah picture of like I did
have a girl say once before not -
because I saw you uh comedy I was like
oh okay cool she's like you're funny
which night was it she goes do you had
your hundred dick out get your junk out
like which one but where's love you got
a nice thick one or just a really long
balls give long balls yeah won't play
the dick detectives
okay you've seen it already can you play
with me are we doing music well no man
well how about this can I guess what
your penis looks like well that would be
the game I know but we don't even
describe it but bulbus at the top this
is not how you play every penis but it
is for me cuz I haven't seen it so can I
guess what it's like and then he can
confirm it I mean if you want just
in the game what's the game has the game
normally go oh sorry it was just an
impromptu idea yeah I like to hide okay
the game is is that we guess what
somebody's penis looks like yeah based
on I don't know what it looks like
yes Tina no no I mean I just noticed
there was a naked guy I wanna I want to
guess what your wiener looks like just
based on what I know about you no way
you remember it yeah okay
the and then what's the normal game no
that's it right this really this is not
how we play the game but the game the
game is we would discuss it they get the
way to do this is that we would have
done this last week and then he comes in
and then we we talked to home about oh
alright alright whatever your victims
the music's
okay well we can discuss it at length
and then after just have no pun intended
pleat right all right I guess you have
really long balls ah
um I think just the admin see your hand
there's only two kinds of people I am I
got it uh that thing is so wrong so off
the hand thing no I dated here the thing
is I my hand is white
can I say something I actually had a
Russian Jew boyfriend yeah and similar
in stature to Ari so I'm gonna go off my
previous experiences right I'm saying
that the hand thing is proven to be
false I know but I'm gonna use what I
have these are these are my deck
detective tools this is my toolbox okay
so you didn't especially didn't guess
yet well I thought you were starting
yours so I go ahead you're the one that
has the quicker assessments huh yeah go
ahead
I'm gonna I'm gonna guess judging by
your height uh-huh and just the shape of
your body let me see the shape of your
hands hands thing again
well because I'm telling you that I can
obviously a rookie detective
you're obviously a new Department uh I'm
gonna guess that your bean bag is a
little purplish in color would you ever
think to ask for look at guys hands we
were thinking of like I wonder if that
guy's like got a giant hog I would never
think of leaving thinking about his
hands well then just go his not big he
was the hand thing is a common actually
they've the size of somebody's body it
has been proven to be not an indicator
people I think it's an indicator they're
like I could I could tell by his nose
all right holders
he's look how tall he is yet there's no
correlation well that's I like Puerto
Rican guys are short and stout but they
can have huge hogs and I know this ooh
right but see that's a there right so
that disproves our the - I think there's
any racial there are any racial like
that has been proven yes it's been
proven that yes Jews have bigger noses
to like to keep up different things the
the fact is the Asians are shorter
that's anger
relax have have a bigger hogs mandingo I
believe the word is you see around and
you're like yeah
says proven okay very it's true okay all
you said is here's purple ball okay well
here's here's what I'm going with this
okay is that again based on a previous
relation right have a guy that looks
just like him
now just like you yeah but he's a
Russian Jew so he's got some terrorist
all right are my god
no no but I did have sex with Micah
really oh yes
how weird that's why but he was a white
guy so okay Micah which one's Micah
which one Russian Manny no one Micah no
no there's just one I can't tell him I
can't go in specifics I don't want to
you know have you guys told each other
about every single person you bet I have
I've been I'm just learning about Micah
no I that was I can't I don't want to go
into more cuz whatever someone I want to
say his name and then you just said
together which is the first name he
knows you guys did it right yeah I told
you talking about it okay so listen so
the one I mean mikonos yeah he knows
okay hey I told her to I've told her it
really no you you give me like vague
estimations I just I don't know their
names but I tell her I told her like
that once what from outside so yeah cuz
I don't but I didn't date them right I
dated everybody I don't remember all of
them I mean like yeah I have to be
something like makes my stomache
sometimes sometimes I'll be like oh I
forgot yeah I forgot about that one
yeah so yeah what just on it's
unbelievable to me maybe because I'm a
woman and you have to let somebody
inside of your body
yeah to me it's a little remember every
guy's name yes every guy I guess
absolutely
I know exactly okay their differences
the guys are worth remembering right ah
that's why it's easier okay here's your
Weiner ready yeah I'm gonna go a bean
bag purplish in color maybe your peeny
your paint are you Russian Jew no you're
just juju Romanian
oh I made my mom's Russian excellent
yeah okay so your Eastern Bloc Jew okay
so your weenus will be purplish and tone
I'm gonna go for a bulbous head the
heads of bulbous not all heads some are
more than others
Jews are too heavy more ballast so head
on it yeah yeah yeah Jews tend and I've
had two Jewish boyfriend's yeah both of
them very bulbous Oh uh-huh
um I would say average length you know
nothing to write home about when flaccid
okay uh-huh
yes um taking shots at him all right no
I'm just kidding it's just biology okay
so yeah he didn't finish what am I gonna
guess on the length wall erect oh yeah
well that's good thinking judging that I
was the only just never laid the game
but have a nice even enough out you did
a lot of description okay what did I say
purpley in tone the hue no that is his
balls are bag you said that basically he
has a dong that has a head and it's a
very bulbous purplish okay in town hey
all right and when flaccid nothing to
write home without okay maybe when erect
he's got I bet he's got a healthy hog
okay I'm gonna go for healthy hog Ari
here's my my assessment comes I really
have no recollection of ever seeing it
no but my recollection my theory is this
somebody that would make the decision to
walk around naked like they pick
themselves out there has to have at
least there's only two people that would
do that somebody that has some
confidence in the size yeah or somebody
that wants to like they'd rather put it
out there that it's so horrible shameful
know that like I think that like like if
it were super small and somebody wanted
to embrace the fact that this is my flaw
that's not you so I feel like you have
the confidence that would arise from
having at least a healthy a good-sized
one oh yeah I'm saying yeah like like a
guy with like a small and soft a small
and soft would probably not make the
decision to go naked I used to at the
comic store we had a foosball table
upstairs yeah I would we would always
love it cock each other yeah I'd really
fucking vigorously worker because I have
to like laugh and try to maintain an
erection
heart and then Jim painting everyone's
attention I run out like seed fluff walk
by wanna see yeah I wouldn't I would way
to go with a boner yeah
Oh interesting I mean flaccid you walked
around flaccid with it out flaccid yeah
so I'm saying flaccid mmm you had to
feel like you were at least comfortable
enough to be having in front of people
because a lot people would agree well GG
Allin had an extremely small Peter yes
and he would parade that around but I
think as he was so high okay oh yeah
that's the other category that I found
out it was not anything schizo I think
based on the act of you doing that
I feel like flaccid you're you're
alright already looking alright like
it's not like a tiny one right and I
feel like when you're fully ready to
pump and dump
yeah I feel like you're I feel like
you're little above average weighing
before you got a nice healthy jus
thickness - I do girth I'm sorry you're
right the Jews have girth I think you're
like seven in length and you got a nice
nice you know
grip on it when you're hold on you're
fuckin the Jew girth is there that's
people say hello yeah okay um and the
bulbous head yeah yeah there you go you
I know Jews um there's no purplish hue
right oh really I mean it's obviously a
little more purple but less than like
promote purple thick mm-hm when soft
shockingly tiny shockingly yeah when
when erect six and a half so I was
pretty pretty good I'm pretty muddy
right there wow you guys
the dick detectives
to make this up sometimes I do
all right yeah
that was uh that was impromptu yeah dick
detective and basically I mean who won
that we both kind of guess but somebody
do you think re when you went to the
length and the size
mmm you described a lot of more that I
wouldn't even think to describe those
details yeah normal woman I deal in
dicks okay a lot of your Luck's under my
belt so many dicks Puerto Rican dicks
Jewish dicks black dicks Chinese dicks
Jesus I was like a dick buffet oh shit
Sarah's gonna throw up what's your a
favorite of all those different with the
pear flavor of their arguments you've
had all the colors of the rainbow like
skittles I have I've had the skills have
you what's the most obvious question
were asking you bring up that you slept
with more parties
the faster you slept the Chinese person
that's most comical I'm sorry I
misunderstood your question I thought
what do people most ask about the
Chinese guy I get asked a lot about a
Chinese egg how was it it was quite
honestly yes below average did you
scream just to make him feel at home
yeah I had a relationship with this
person oh really you know what's however
waking moss you got it up you played up
there yeah you got it well depressing no
because I loved him I loved mr. person
it's irrelevant it's just depressing to
think about ya know can I tell you the
most disappointing one was a white guy
really just a white white well one-timer
I know this story is that the one I'm
thinking of yes the one you had to quit
on yes and that one I couldn't you
couldn't she's quit oh no that was dick
wait no the teeny-tiny that's what I'm
talking about
you cats not what do you mean I quit
broke up with that oh but wasn't it
after not a lot of hooking up right that
was after minimal hooking erect yes and
you were like this is so it's pitiful it
was the reason there was the reason to
break up yes see you guys letting on
that Wow
yes sad huh when you're like nobody
really cares about you who's gonna kick
that's wrong they're not gonna get to
care about you gonna get in the way you
know and all in all fairness though I
think had his personality been different
maybe I would make concessions yeah you
say that stuff I would simply say that
Andres Psalms and all the girls when
they read of Tom time like would you
ever date him
he's kind of self-centered yeah remember
like really nothing to do it the
porringer pounds nothing I'd be gonna
bring that up who's that it's not even
that sounds familiar that name address
Alton yeah he was a comic for a while
and like a real tech guy uh-huh
we grew up there and said it with a
notepad who grew up with like a tablet
okay yeah I know that guy hmm Oh girls
would be like obviously they would use
the excuse yeah he's sort of but women
are more forgiving though that part is
true I think a physical appearance
absolutely absolutely more forgiving but
right but I'm saying yeah I did there
there are guys like let's say not him
yeah all over Hollywood you have nerds
getting laid by hot but I mean all over
the world like I'm saying you you'll buy
guy yeah who's like let's say like that
with that physique can end up where
maybe not that bad but you know a really
bad for some offs um we'll end up with
like a can end up with an attractive
woman do you want to forgive is awful
physique uh yeah hey summer you got some
ourselves I know Manuel Uribe uh the
3,000 pound guy in Mexico yeah well he
has a girlfriend he's a wife now really
that guy that's bedridden short morbid
get married on the show yeah they took
him on a forklift Israel on the world's
fattest man yeah
TLC did a thing about him Manuel Uribe
and he does his exercise flat bed around
for his furnace for the wedding ceremony
a flatbed drove through town Tino went
like this really yeah he was he was over
a thousand pounds when he got married
yeah and he goes lost 2,000 pounds no no
his highest weight is like 1,300 oh and
he lost like 300 and they're like you
know you looking at staying there's no
tuxedos it made for you so I don't know
what you're doing yeah there's just
there's sheets around them in their leg
I and then he was so happy to get
married he married a woman who weighed a
hundred and five pounds normal yeah and
she used to powder his bean bag remember
how dur all of his his growth he had
like fat deposits some of the fat
deposits would weigh like 80 90 pound
how bad is Mexico no you know where he
got back was he goes a move to America
until Texas and I sold the pizza and
cheeseburgers and I started to eat all
yeah so was actually when he came to the
states he said he started they started
to show his weight gain it was like it's
not like a kind of regular-sized dude
and then maybe to start with right yeah
when he got to like he lived in Texas
for a couple years and he got to be just
like your your standard fat like fat
dude like 300 and some pounds okay
you're like well I see that everywhere
here wobblers right
cz dudes like three 350 and then it just
he went back to Mexico and it started to
just snowball like Boise we took the
recipe with him he took all the recipe
we took that and then he was 400 and
then basically I talked to a
nutritionist one time about it or a
physician who said that like once you
hit like over for really it's read
that's when it really becomes a
challenge to go backwards like if you
hit for something really so easy to go
five six seven but you know I mean like
but you're so disgusting or what if and
when and it's just like you're already
you're consuming special calories and
you start to become less mobile so you
start packing it on because the simple
math starts to add up you're not moving
you're not burning anything your diet
you're taking in like you know you're
taking in what is it five figures every
day in calories well which is people
everyone they're all taking in 10,000
thousand calories plus weight do you
remember that he lived in the third or
fourth storey and he would lower a
bucket yeah the money yeah and the
Chinese delivery takeout guy or chicken
nerd in the bucket and then he could
wheel it up so they would cook for him
this is a different guy
whoa check they would cook crazy amounts
of food for him although he would still
call delivery places ain't below a
bucket out he put a bucket out like on a
rope knows money and then they would put
food in the bucket he'd pull so he would
eat in hiding after they just cook
dinner for him Wow yeah and then the
next day they'd be like well these boxes
like what happened he like I know right
so do you feel like that do you feel
like I'm Manuel Uribe yeah I think
that's the end you've managed to find
some kind somebody normal
that's a different that's an enabler
like that woman that woman has a nurse a
Nightingale syndrome what if what is
that call the Nightingale thing where
you want to take care of somebody who's
in mobile you're just like with me
because I met you when I weighed much
less so you actually you had a different
person to marry I've grown into this I'm
sorry but I'm fatter too than when we
married it kind of goes both ways babe
this is no but I'm sorry but when we met
we met I was I mean very very very
handsome but you still are very very how
much do you weigh now uh you don't know
1040 Oh something like that - for wot
man but yeah you don't feel like but I
don't feel that your big approach don't
over them no but you're just like a
regular fat you're not like fat yeah
yeah like a you know water oh no did you
touch Tommy he's solid like your money
pushing it out so Kim has had a chance
no but chocolate Tommy works out a lot
and he's physically very soon I don't
work out I do have a bad diet I mean I
know what I have to do to lose weight
it's not like us yeah but you're solid
meat you're like a linebacker like I
feel like you're your football playing
deal yeah you seem strong okay I do I do
I lift weights every week I mean well
you hear that is that a cat we're done
we cat
uh yeah I just have a horrible horrible
diet I hate that um yeah wait but you
you're just naturally thin right sort of
gray a little more than you
mmm I do but then I I put stipends on
that um diet with a bunch of skittles
and gummy bears yeah yeah but you like
so you like but your vice is more like
candy and stuff like that
see I'm my fatness comes from my vice is
like high fat foods like hamburgers I
love a burger yeah a small shit like
that you're garbage you know I do when I
go on the road I he died yeah basically
he's like it's too hard to get rarely I
rarely ever eat candy
really no no a mine is uh mozzarella
sticks after or in between shows that
I've done I never really an excuse for
cheese the I would say oh nine was my
work here on the yeah yeah that was like
every club five nights a week whatever
they had you would eat chicken fingers
down 71 of the roof of the year just
featuring no that was not yours it for
the year
Oh seven is when I featured at every
club but I'm saying and I got fat for
sure mmm-hmm but I'm saying when it went
like bat like and I got fat eating I was
eating garbage then I was eating garbage
no 8:07 is where I featured every club
oh nine is when I started headlining a
lot of clubs and I really was eat like
traveling a lot no and you know like it
started to wear on me and I ate like
fucking shit and then at the end of oh
nine going into 2010 I was like I had to
do so like I've actually gotten way
healthier oh that's cool yeah I mean
I've lost you know I don't know how many
pounds but I've gotten like I eat you've
lost a lot of weight since our wedding
Oh God definite wedding is really bad
really bad would you guys get married oh
wait wait
I just ate I was in a terminal in Dallas
and all they had was Burger King and
Taco Bell like those are my food options
there are places that will put you up in
a place where there's no food even
available for delivery after 11:00 p.m.
you know and they know you're getting
back laying how can you put me up here
there's nothing here or Sunday's it's
clever disclose on Sunday in fucking oh
we may know anywhere do people give you
pot on the road because they know so
you're like yeah yeah they're pretty
cool about it usually people I'll try to
find some two by two but easier people
bring me something give me a joint you
don't travel with yeah it's smart
um I travel that I'm gonna fight like
it's hard to me okay I don't know
yeah I'm not jealous I just think I'd
join it you with me but that's not a
little a that's that's to get me through
to the next day when I go to the club
yeah you bring like breath strips or
something not smellable yeah oh yeah
totally those edibles but it's like a
different hot it's like a big-time hi
big tank what's adventure when I was at
Cobbs a week after you know the sorry
the day after you more people were like
yeah re just like God
age and then immediately got high on
this I don't like that sound that
everybody just bring no it was like
let's take pictures let's just do it
right over here and it was like 18
joints are going around just like I can
breathe after a while that you have
you're like a folk hero in the yeah I
mean like you've become one of the guys
like you know you realize in a few years
yeah like as this continues to grow
you're you're going to be like you know
you're going to have the same level of
fandom and and weed associated with it I
think that as like a Doug Benson or oh
yeah it's great
yeah it's great yeah they'll be awesome
yeah it's not a problem at all it's
having to Claire Abruzzo also some
Toronto comic yeah once when I was there
for something like a year and a half of
course or maybe a year ago mhm and uh
some dude was just walking on the street
it was like hey Ari Shaffir
it's like yep it was Transpo could join
me that's rad if you have a joint yep I
never smoked and then he left Jesus
you're gonna be like yeah she's like
what was that like the first time it's
ever happened that's gonna happen a lot
more like lot a lot more I think it's
gonna remember this one Co her shot seal
it shut oh yeah
the people like that live podcast you
guys did yes people like listening to it
later yeah I got some complaints yeah
about you know some people complain
about the audio some people I'm playing
about no they're like because it is a
different sound to like the live thing
and overall overall hugely positive I
did get you know it was a departure from
from the norm he's different
like a jokey more yeah and people were
like I didn't like some people like I
didn't like you had different get I mean
you know overall it was positive so we I
thought if I were doing for a skeptic
think I would just get like I would have
to do it like there's no way you could
do it live it'd be too long yeah so
that's like three of our people and just
cover real quick yeah I thought that
helped us doing that well I like doing
it in front of a live audience yeah yeah
keep it moving so I think before you
read the new ones let's tell people you
got some results
sorry don't just put it out there last
week's who do you want in I didn't
really say anything I was just sort of
stuck or seal shut and we put we had a
color while we're sealed shut
well fill up and seal show yeah in
addition you want to fill er up then you
want to seal it show so that no other
load will be there tomorrow right that's
nice you're under it and it takes
multiple loads to do this have to really
keep keep a fill it up you have to fill
it up or go down by filling it up and
then when it gets to the very end then
you can seal it sucks - it's like trying
to feel like a hole in the wall and you
got to keep filling it into a spackling
back when yeah so we we put out there
who would you rather fill up a seal shut
Michelle Pfeiffer as Catwoman okay in
that role I'm for Linda Carter as
original Wonder Woman as Wonder Woman uh
yeah I think Linda Carter she was one of
the first people I paid off to
staying backstory personal the fans you
know they it was it was kind of close
shit oops shed boobs under Carter yeah
yeah ah shit even know what she a model
before that I don't know what the fuck
she did it wasn't that she was like a
superhero it was just that she was
wearing this bathing suit or nothing
and she's Wonder Woman think about it I
mean if she has what she can do as
Wonder Woman there's got to be they're
not gonna talk about on the show there's
gotta be some runoff about what she can
do to your cock
I mean she's Wonder Woman the last you
think it's just regular sex with Wonder
Woman she's a wonder pussy she has to
know and I don't even think about you
know oh right when I wager woman like
Superman doesn't have a regular dick
he's got Superman's dick wait a minute
though
Wonder Woman historically comes from an
all-female Island it's like an island of
Lesbos
she probably don't know what she's doing
yeah yeah but then also you put your
dick in there in lightning bolts go
through your dish and like oh shit
yeah blowjobs would be unbelievable
there we go now you're goin missin room
for cock listeners uh fuck so far we're
waiting we're right at a Cinemax movie
right now you know that right yeah uh
the listeners voted 42 to 32 okay
Pfeiffer Wow they kept Pfeiffer yeah
wanted that coked out look and they got
it there you guys the next one not you
put out there was who would you like to
fill you up and seal you shut okay oh
did you want captain james t kirk or han
solo yeah no wait when did you get these
people when did we put them out yeah the
the last week that's what and then that
they've written back since then they
have a snot hit some votes yeah if you
want to vote it's very simple
facebook.com slash your mom's house
podcast just kidding
okay so once again facebook.com slash
your mom's house podcast you can vote
and you can comment you can do whatever
you want there with votes alright um
that's interesting Michelle Pfeiffer is
kind of a cloth so any Kitty's solo
rushed it as I predicted you would yeah
solar whoohoo over Captain Kirk alright
so far yeah lame
yeah yeah that's I was fuckin cool man
you know what he smokes you know yeah
they don't shut but you you know he
smoked he probably he probably does shit
like a fucking smacks you around maybe
holds your head down I think so low I
think so no I think so low would so was
like at times I guys like oh oh gee
really yeah never I think that's also
tight I think so low she's been all over
the fucking universe crushing personal
and it's hot you Baca is fucking his
wing man come on but Honda's done so
quickly for it no I was like a blue sky
rock yeah exactly
yeah solo solo yeah hot so loud I waited
about and tie your head down and make it
out of a dog bowl to you no I don't
think so I think he lets the pussy come
to him he's so cool and collected
I'm solo yeah we have different theories
okay get ready to making new versions
just every time he leaves a classic
scene in Star Wars you see him just go
beat us why for some grass and girls
like suck my dick with my balls person
can't do shit our chests shit on my
chest that I can solder lessons like
another thing you'll sing yeah I'm so
low can't come unless you do really
really gross nothing to do with being
Darth Vader but that's why I didn't come
but a lightsaber in his ass I've been
fucking fun out of the universe for
years you don't know how many weird
pussies I've seen yeah cuz he's seen
like a lady I know you're right now I
just thought of that like the way that
guy's got a prize yeah the place he goes
like yeah I'm getting some plumbers I
guess some galactic puss I got a vagina
inside a vagina that's getting warmer
for that race I want to see what that's
like
he's fucking different species yeah
should I didn't consider that was always
Captain Kirk though Captain Kirk
actually oh yeah that green ugly girl he
actually did bang chicks on different
planets point/counterpoint yeah yeah
and he was one of those burpees to clean
up um if you would could you read uh who
do we
all right so this week we're going to do
female athletes starting we're going to
do multiple athletes so we're gonna
start with the ladies
we're covering Mia Hamm she's not on our
list we had to look at a lot of athletes
I felt like I mean although she's very
famous let's keep him famous you know
because there's like a citrus zacharias
this is a list of so many of these like
there's this girl who smells like he's
just golf players like the best golfer
ever like Blair O'Neill have you seen
her
uh uh she's smoking hot but I get you
know I don't people to have like most
like you know who's who's who there is
that MMA girl that's had grown up yeah I
used to beat up the Steffi Graf Oh a
city girl oh yes
Oh which one's the other one what does
one average one over oh yeah what's the
super Daiki one nation is that one thin
enough alone yeah yeah yeah yeah Steffi
Graf married what's his name Andre
Agassi right oh that's tabs we got
stabbed in the neck oh I know you're
talking about we I see married somebody
yeah yeah no Jennifer Capriati yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah she just you earned it oh
my god sorry she died
what did she know his heart I could see
maybe posing she did porn wait I'm
looking it up right now
oh no we're neighbors making popcorn you
smell that
yeah I smell it smells awesome Jennifer
Capriati the one she got into drugs and
all that shit right yeah yeah okay yeah
and if she made a comeback and she like
once a major all right
anyway so there's there's a party but so
did you right are you ready go for it
okay so for this edition we're going to
do Maria Sharapova okay beautiful blonde
ruski is she rue ski she's Rebecca yeah
yeah background yeah okay and then good
old-fashioned America
Danica Patrick Danica Patrick Donna good
Danica Patrick Danica Patrick so you
have shoes if she doesn't go daddy
commercials
basically you have NASCAR yes she's a
racecar driver and you have a tennis
player at very different worlds both hot
both well-known I realized there was you
know there's like I said this other golf
player sandra Gal I mean just like smoke
hot nobody fucking knows or some of
these other tennis players that were
super hot
Morgan knows them 10 so we're sticking
to two very well-known who do you want
to feel fill up in sealed shut
Maria Sharapova the tennis player Zdenek
Danica Patrick the superhot racecar
driver
here's what I'm thinking well Sharapova
really knows how to move got the long
leg on super hot
Danica racecar driver got a lot of
grease in her hands got a lot of grease
in her snatch easy to get up in there
you know shove it in her ass and she's
just got motor oil and all kinds of
parts sitting around probably you know
someone who wants to get out it's an
interesting theory town and the grease
if you want that grease in your asshole
yeah yep
what do you think Ari I think I think
Danica Patrick is probably a lot heavier
than everybody knows those weren't full
bodysuits they're going quick cuts on
her is what Chubby's heavy but I saw
some bikini pictures of her actually
when I googled really she actually like
does spreads and like men's flag type
shit yeah that's good to know
I mean maybe that eccentric done cuz I
don't you have to be in shape to do you
like your driver should be too hard
who's that Sharapova think so I think
it'd be the tougher stomach would be
like it's like you could hit it you know
like that it's too hard
you know it to be a driver you have to
have a lot of muscle strength actually I
think it's quite a merry something about
me yeah I'm always hard never soft
always
is that weird yeah look how coin he got
for a minute
he kind of blushed and then he gave you
a special yeah
kisses with the guys yeah Wow love
connection uh so you would you feel like
she's too athletically I think she's
gotten big
do you like soft lick softer I like soft
a little jiggle but still thin
yeah it's not like hard I think she'd be
too muscular you're not attracted to
bodybuilders right oh no yeah no not at
all
yeah no you rather fill up and seal shut
well I know I predict okay go ahead I
think you viewed more bit you'd be more
attracted to Sharapova's type yak I tell
you why cuz I'm a narcissist I like
blondes like me and I like Eastern
Europeans like me I don't trust American
like all-american girl I think that all
Americans can be uptight like Danica's
probably a good girl mm-hmm so she won't
you see this shows GoDaddy commercials
yeah just take it off or don't don't act
like it's a surprise well yeah I'm
you're against it it's up to you do you
want to put some more washer fluid into
Danica or it would you like to smell it
in a spray and Sharapova's asshole it
might be hard to seal up down ago with
all the grease there so does the extra
work involved too is sealing up then a
good like that how the loads in there
guys point well as we're doing athletes
let's keep it up we'll do one for the
women ladies who would you rather be
filled up and sealed shut by mm-hmm uh
we have Tom Brady New England Patriots
quarterback odd handsome fella gorgeous
yeah marry to Giselle dress as well and
I smile yes
all right so Tom Brady or David Beckham
card from international heartthrob
that's at the heart stomach you don't
like though yeah yeah you're right
buddy's married today I'd like it on
dude do you if you had to choose between
those two do you feel like it either one
my first as is right away Brady but then
I'm like no
like an English accent might be kind of
cool yeah good nice to have around I
think I think Beckham tries a little
more I think he's more of a pleaser
interesting lady sits back mate listen
you fucking play quarterback in New
England you already have rings Mary to
Giselle I think he's just like seriously
and like you know even if like if you're
with a measly I can spit on it do a
little work like like hey are you gonna
fill me up
he's like fill your fucking self up
that's a radius also if any whatever
possibility they bring their whoever
they're dating in - just just watch not
even joint images to watch yeah then
filling you up yeah I'd rather have posh
spice looking at me then and she
salvages only sat next to selling a
plane once fuck that bitch yeah really
know what you do I feel like by the way
Beckham is a soccer player stamina for
days oh yeah really wear you out you
talked about getting sealed shut
yeah Beckham can do it eh I say my
theory here I think that posh spice is
not a good lay she's real skinny she's
real self-involved she's probably not
putting it out a lot she's got kids I
think David Beckham's just starving for
it for some good fucking holes close to
bill yeah and who knows what kind of
holds there ah my holes all right you
know the huge is Beckham yeah I'm gonna
go with David Beckham so Brady you're
like that guy's cute he's all he's a
very all-american stunner yes uh yeah
looks like he could be on like the
pamphlet for Yale or something that's
why I don't like America that's what it
it yeah it's too clean it's too perfect
don't you want to fuckin be good yeah
give me some trouble yeah I need a
little yeah scumbag Davis Davis Casa Z
up tattoos a bit it's all kinds of yeah
like yeah items got like 15 Brady's got
nothing like there's got one swastika
like Tesco okay now and then of course
we didn't want you guys to be like hey
there's a kind of a theme going on here
yeah a lot of white faces yeah so we
decided to extend it and give you a
little you know a little little spice in
your sauce you know I'm saying yeah so
here's some a couple other athletes here
we go I don't know this is Tommy's pic I
put these together yeah
you guys I get filled up or sealed shut
by all right Marshawn Lynch Marshawn
Lynch okay okay or Pacman Jones okay now
these are football players they are both
football players yeah they're both
African American they're both the kind
of guys that like if you were laying
around and they walked in on you you
just see that's how you feel either one
and they both are definitely into
filling it up and sealing it shut I'm
pretty a hundred percent certain they
both already have kids so they know how
to fill it up until a shot however they
both are launched on a car they're
posted on the league they are both still
in the league Pacman Jones still pac-man
is with the bangles let me take a look
at this Marshawn I don't know how much
site let's look at him I kind of I think
I know pac-man yeah Marshawn Lynch is
with the Seahawks yeah yeah so but they
both yeah that both definitely it's a
it's a it's a it's a different style
than a Brady or a Beckham okay oh oh
that's oh but I mean kind of luck okay
Little John but not everybody wants the
same good won't your iPhone won't let
you enlarge that picture because it's
scary enough when you see I want to show
our viewers at home can I see this
this is Marshawn Lynch sure
it's kind of hard to see oh there you go
yeah there you soon so he's got
beautiful women there smiling yeah he
show you his grill okay but I'm I'm
actually trying to make a point here
which is that not everybody likes the
same thing right so some that might be
the most desirable thing for one of our
listeners all right again build up a
seal shut by Marshawn Lynch look he's
gonna talk uh salt uh rough in the
roughneck yet who sing that song about
Roughnecks oh I forget some rap group
girl rap group yeah yes all buff
Nickerson yeah yeah now wait a minute
this guy Pac Man is a little similar to
Marshawn yeah got the dreads I don't see
any grills yeah that's why you have to
pick who you want to get filter is a
solid prison record Pac Man John they
know that he does yeah what do they like
his people do what do we know about
these two
well let's not let's just go off of a
status tedx okay Wow personally this is
type of bias in this one man I don't
want to get Warren and I'm daddy and I
really wanted bangles to have a good
year uh-huh so I'm willing to get sealed
shut by Pacman Jones and we're that good
of the team yoked uh this guy will break
me in half yeah that's what I want to
see we do it is so terrifying to get
destroyed my vision look they both look
like that that whole thing is a grill
road so head off I'm going away from the
grill if I just wonder you're all so
real yeah unless he's got a grill and
then it's like no it's like you guys
chose my shelves who do you want babe
I'm afraid of the grill too I think
that's going to be a massively share for
me there is a trio going for Pacman
Jones marshawn's terrifying I'm gonna
the grill make some scary well you know
what you said moments ago that you
needed a little edge
that's too much edge the fold the full
grill is too much for me okay all right
hey call me uptight all right you heard
it there when you can go to hopefully
these will be the the polls will be up
facebook.com slash your mom's house
podcast and everyone knows Pacman Jones
at Marshawn Lynch please tell them to
write in and explain why they work you
know them good okay killer I better um
see Marshall
uh more quads and asked like he's lower
level like look his legs are much
stronger no so I think he would just
absolutely at heart just last we work
completely you think he would shatter
your pelvis but maybe you know what if
if I'm if I'm going in for something
like that maybe that's what you want
that's what I'm saying
pac-man I think he's gonna he's gonna
he's definitely gonna sit on your face
no pac-man is I think marshawn's gonna
sit on your face and make you lick his
butthole and so he says you're done
don't you say that yes that face that
makes you eat a butthole he says you're
ready
what is your wow that's really
aggressive how you do it my life do you
like it or not that's what we want to
know who do you want to get filled up a
sous chef I it's this the three of us
have chosen Pacman Jones I think if you
if you were telling by these guys what
you might be into Pacman Jones would at
least wait til you finish talking
but most halfway through like shut the
fuck up
Thank You Pietra Lee yeah yeah you're
right I think and he would forcibly is
fucking bullshit damn
fuck off me LeBron bitch motherfucker
okay deal Brown you're black bitch and
fuck you
oh that bitch fuck fuck this shit like
that who's that that's my dad yeah no we
we had that play the last few weeks
people acid he uh people that asked it
uh fasted that asked us to post it I
didn't even know it existed on YouTube
so I would look for on YouTube and I
couldn't find it I had a different
source but somebody else found it so
we'll put it on the website we if I give
you for sure website up and then it'll
you can all see the link it's a it's
just a dad playing video games with his
son they have put a camera recording
loving so if father-son night it's
really ups I think it's really really
really you know fucking suck this big
ass motherfucker just dad yeah black
mother fuckin something on the school
dad huh cuz its son beat him they're
playing they're playing the game as
they're playing the dad's fucking losing
huh Jesus Christ that's we play is we
play is drop all the time pretty awesome
yeah so look we got a fucking we gotta
wrap this shit up man
alright money uh clears really really
cool thing real quick the next episode
after this one which will debut in
another week or so we're going to have
an update one that you've been asking
for you've been asking for it for a
while you've been wanting to know it
you've said you've said yeah what is
that what is that you wanted to know
where the dudes are at okay and that
Harvey well I mean you know everybody
wants to know what is that well I have
an update I'm not going to give it to
you but I reconnected with our good
friend Casey who initially you know
that's that's where it all started and
he was willing to come on and talk to us
everybody knows if you've if you don't
know about the story it's it's too much
to get into we could maybe post a link
to a previous episode yeah where we get
into you know here's a little of his
when he when he called me initially you
know let me just start by saying that
you're probably the best friend I've
ever had
most reliable most dependent
most caring came to the friend of the
red but so I just thought of that but
what I want from you is yes I want to
link to the podcast where you told the
story because I went to you to the
podcast site and I'm listening to the
one that I thought has a story in it and
if you realize your podcast or two hours
long so I'm not going to listen to all
two hours until I get to the part where
you're telling us where to do that story
that of course is Casey from a long time
ago and he just went little bit where
the dudes are at I am so we reconnected
we talked all about it and yes this is
like a super tease for the next episode
breaking we're gonna find out live where
we'll find out where they are I just
wanna know the dudes out so bad it's it
everybody wants to know what you guys
read you know where where are the dudes
I don't know they could be anywhere give
me anywhere
Casey knows there are that sometimes
they're in Dallas to everybody's an
Frances I know everybody we didn't you
mention this that ordered the top dog
shirt we thank you very much and they
all ship out tomorrow we'll actually by
the time this is posted they will have
already shipped out if you want them
please get them they're at your mom's
house podcast calm we're super excited
about them they look great it's awesome
it's my favorite shirt it's my favorite
thing we've done so far on is my
favorite ever ever is the dopest shirt
yeah let me know yeah I'll show it to
you here gonna land
so yeah they're there it's the official
it's our it's going to be our official
podcast shirt so if you want them you
know where to get them and that is all
is there anything else you want to throw
out there I haven't have them coming out
Wow tell us about it I think it's gonna
be August 7th are you serious yeah
that's awesome better timeline for not
the same week because I'm going on in
August
okay so I'll do it separate weeks okay
yeah well what's it called Deena have a
name yet revenge for the Holocaust right
now you I thought you were pretty
outspoken Holocaust denier right um I
just see facts man and I'm just waiting
to see uh foolproof yeah I mean anyone
can make a video anyone can mark what is
this a field yeah I don't know yeah and
then you just have a bunch of people
there skinning that my dev is survivor I
gotta stop this she's gonna hear this
really what are you doing our it shows
our families wiped out what are you
doing yeah that should happen it's so
crazy that Ari would be what like that's
not I mean a few people definitely died
I'll give you that they're all right
here these numbers I don't know maybe
100 people Tom Barrett's always says
he's like I saw this documentary and it
just seemed like the Nazis weren't even
that's put together they were like
bumbling they can really get anything
done it wasn't that high low like what
documentary is that nose I think was
called Hogan's Heroes it just seemed
like they didn't have it that hard
what was that just cut out I don't know
yeah oh did you flip your switch genes
do you think that is out completely yeah
you do I still yeah for me too
oh did your hair phones die justing you
don't hear hear you know yourself know
if I snapped if you don't have you know
I hear now here again Oh giggle the
cords that was really scary
I thought you weren't even alive for a
second okay whatever ated oh I want to
thank the Dallas mommies that came out I
got to move uh
Reid and Christina they're like the
coolest people and a lot of other
mommies that came out thank you so much
it really makes my week a lot happier
hey I get to meet you I was in Dallas
with Justin Martindale
yeah
he went on Grindr no two random dudes at
1:00 in the afternoon to have a
three-way with never bone that's right
he did he just got Willy what he got one
and then he likes start but he wouldn't
get right back so it was like start with
another was like our urine the first
guys okay I'll come in like 20 minutes
goes well I already got somebody you
wanna man Wow to be a gay man that a
great night what a great life
yeah just fuckin alright I just had this
app that finds dead world's got fuckin
we wait at the afternoon some
unbelievable see and that's clearly why
you want to know what it is it they
should rename the grinder app yeah uh-oh
it's yeah who are you releasing your
album with you figure it out Ari Shaffir
enterprises yeah buddy
hi me too awesome I'm self-releasing
mine too yeah
so fuck it's different now it's
different yeah sorry
do you know Warner Brothers gonna do
just say it's Warner Brothers you find
out did you just decide on who you're
actually like uploading it with you pick
that no I didn't pick that it I'll show
you what I learned
yeah it's like you got to go with some
company that says we'll do it for you
pay us like 50 bucks and you're with us
I'll show you the two things that I was
thinking about okay and then why I think
one is better
oh really okay um but that is all for us
it's really exciting or you know and
time someone write my new ones come in
second or third my second one yeah okay
I shoot the cover tomorrow by the way
guys the cover for Tom's album is gonna
be retarded Lee you're gonna make sure
when you haven't got it
yeah it's lessons pretty great thanks
man yeah the net this one I'm really
excited about yeah I had to put a lot of
effort into making really yeah yeah Wow
I'm excited I want to see it I was gonna
be cold I can't answer that other yeah
but but is it but I will tell you this
there is a track on the album can I tell
you which one it is
I don't member what number one of the
tracks is called where the dudes at no
no so you have is a straight comedy or
you're doing any sketches or anything
it's just a stand-up comic - yeah yeah
yeah that'd be so hard to do some skit
like Adam Sandler Mike you guys wanted
that too he had sketched in his I think
Larson didn't Larson Larson his sketches
in his album
does he really think so Jay Larson has a
sketch person yeah
okay we got to get out of here my mommy
love you guys thank you for for
listening and um I'm re the great calm
yes and uh right that's where we go
thanks for being here all right well I
mean your mom's house podcast calm we
love you and we'll see you soon
what is that well I have a song for you
I like to do with the I'd like to go to
the bar
plug in behind five listen to him talk
trash on there talking about mom vodcast
out there laughing ain't gonna happen
the fix for a piss-poor day this day
discourse and make swords get the
pitchforks listen my bail hey you're in
jail linking with your Porter we can
sell mate or when you tailgate listen
before the game starts played cards
listen my tea shop it's in the king
party on
a big secret I'm often seated in the
kitchen listening the time and Justina
at the end of a rough day get along and
grind get my nightshade if I'm lucky get
it then I loved a room just great like
the devil loves flames like the devil
loves have never ever knew love snakes
this is just the thing to help your
nerves and calm down
I like me now bitch welcome to your
mom's house
freshman fresh up the chinking my house
kitchen man we got the kitchen man
taking my house things double-double for
the range freshmen fucking taking my
house the chicken man we got the kitchen
man taking mom's house
your mom's house starting pristine up
the city
special appearance flat top though could
actually happen to me Orlando Airport
rush and joke though is there anything
work
firing round your mom's house your mom
says
please don't settle for the change
freshmen pressure